(chimes)
Okay, so Women's Health II, nothing to disclose.
We're gonna take a look at breast issues,
contraception and infertility.
And let's start with this question.
A 51-year-old presents to the office,
complaint of a left breast mass.
She reports she was in an automobile accident
five months ago, and first noted the mass at that time.
She thought it was due to the seatbelt she was wearing.
Upon exam, you note a one centimeter hard mass
in the upper outer quadrant of the left breast.
It's mobile and non-tender.
There's no overlying change in the skin,
the nipple discharge or nipple retraction.
You review her chart
and you note that she had
a negative screening mammogram six months ago.
Here's the question.
Which of the following
is the first diagnostic imaging study
that should be performed.
ultrasound, MRI, mammogram or CT?
Okay, you know what this is?
It's a learning opportunity.
The correct answer is mammogram.
Mammogram, regardless of when she had her last one.
The first exam is a mammogram.
So 90% of palpable masses in women
when we're looking at them
between 20 and fifties are benign.
The benign mass may be solid or cystic.
Malignant masses tend to be cystic,
but a cystic mass, which has some solid components,
IE a complex, this could be malignant as well.
Now on the benign side, fibroadenoma cysts,
fibrocystic changes, galactocele, fat necrosis.
On the malignant side, as we said on day one,
infiltrating ductal malignancy is the most common.
It accounts for 70% of invasive breast cancers in the US.
How do we evaluate this?
Well we want to characterize the mass initially,
are there associated nodes?
And then I've gotta do breast imaging
and a diagnostic mammogram, which should be started here.
Now they may need an ultrasound also.
We know over the age of 40,
mammogram is the first test.
Under the age of 30,
ultrasound is the first test.
Between the ages of 30 and 40,
it's kind of a toss up what one you do first,
if both are needed.
MRI not indicated for the work of a benign undiagnosed mass.
Only when you have a diagnostic dilemma
or a surgical dilemma.
Now a biopsy will be needed if it's a mass confirmed.
Core needle biopsy could be used.
This will potentially identify a simple cyst
if it completely goes away.
The image guidance can be helpful here,
because I can place a clip and at that point,
if I need an open biopsy, the surgeon knows where to go.
Okay, 32-year-old breastfeeding female comes to the office
with redness over her right breast and a fever of 101.
The redness started three days ago,
and the fever within the past 12 hours.
She delivered via cesarean two weeks ago,
remained in the hospital seven days
because she suffered from endomyometritis.
She's non-toxic in appearance.
Her exam reveals a hard, red, tender,
swollen area over the right breast.
It measures four by six centimeters.
There's no axillary adenopathy.
The remainder of the examination is normal.
Here's the question.
Which one of the following
would be the appropriate management option?
Dicloxacillin, Clindamycin, Cephalexin, or Augmentin.
Okay, this is a patient specific question.
You gotta look at the details here.
Okay, learning opportunity number two,
Clinda is the correct answer.
Now, mastitis on an exam or in practice,
almost all of them will be lactational.
If it is non-lactational, I'm worried.
Most of this will be staph aureus.
But MRSA is becoming an increasing pathogen.
Most of the time you're seeing a patient
about 48 hours or 72 hours into this
because they're trying things at home.
So by the time you see them, most will need antibiotics.
Very important.
Breastfeeding continues from the affected infected breast.
You do not store milk from the affected infected breast
but you would want to breastfeed.
And actually you'd like to always start the breastfeeding
on that side because emptying of the breast
is really important.
I'm gonna tell, I'm telling you one thing.
Everybody needs to relax their foreheads.
I'm seeing this.
I love you guys, but just relax them.
You're doing great.
Okay, now here's what it looks like.
There could be an abscess under there.
Now many of these patients
will present with systemic complaints.
They've got a flu-like illness.
Reactive lymphadenopathy, not uncommon here.
Now, what could you have?
You could have a blocked duct.
You could have a galactocele.
But in a patient who has non lactational mastitis,
if they don't respond,
I'm thinking inflammatory breast cancer.
I have a patient about a year and a half ago
who came in, here was her chief complaint.
And when I give just a talk on breast disease,
I use this slide.
My boyfriend says one of my breasts
is larger than the other.
I'm like, well, what do you think?
I don't know, Dr. Weismiller.
They look right to me.
She turned out to have inflammatory breast cancer.
I mean, the other, one was one and a half times
the size of the other.
And she's like, oh, I didn't notice there was a difference.
All this, ew.
You know, peel looking on the skin.
Mm, I'm like, okay, inflammatory breast cancer.
Not common, only accounts for about 3% of 'em.
So a non-severe infection would be Diclox.
However, if they're at increased risk for MRSA,
now you're gonna say, well,
wouldn't every patient who's delivered a baby
be at increased risk?
Well, she had a prolonged hospital stay
and had recent antibiotics.
Then any domicile living, incarceration, military service,
and then of course, you know,
HIV infection predisposes you to almost anything.
Here, if it's a non-severe infection, no MRSA, Diclox.
Non-severe infection with risk of MRSA,
Clinda severe infection.
Ooh, this patient doesn't look well.
Remember, that's what we have to,
I remind interns all the time,
the only thing you need to know
by the end of your first year
is if the patient's sick or not sick, right,
'cause you're gonna supervise.
And if you don't know that
and the patient's sick and you don't know what to do,
you don't know to call for help.
If they're sick and you know what to do,
you know, oh, I gotta get started here
'cause this patient doesn't look well.
Okay, now, Paget's Disease of the Breast,
I've only seen three cases of this in 30 years
and each time it was a residents patient.
And here's what they came in and told me.
This patient, the nipple and areola looks really weird.
It's almost like eczema Dr. Weismiller.
Oh, that doesn't sound good.
So when you get Paget's Disease of the Breast,
one to 3% of new cases of female breast cancer
will have this as the predisposing issue.
They get this scaly raw area.
85% of them have an underlying malignancy.
That's why I don't want to hear about this.
This is what it looks like, various presentations,
but it's basically eczema of the nipple.
Now it could be eczema, it could be a contact dermatitis,
it could be a nipple adenoma, malignant side,
squamous carcinoma, epidermis, basal cell,
or superficial spreading malignant melanoma.
The way we buy, the way we diagnosis it is biopsy.
They're not gonna ask you about the intraepithelial
adenocarcinoma cells called paget cells.
They might tell you the biopsy shows
the intraepithelial adenoma, adenocarcinoma cells.
Bilateral mammography.
And of course the prognosis here
is dependent on what is the underlying malignancy,
if there is one.
Okay, contraception.
Combined hormonal options.
We've got many vehicles.
Pill, ring, patch,
they all inhibit ovulation
of the pituitary and hypothalamus.
In general, it's a Ethinylestradiol.
Keep in mind with all the progestins,
the newest progestin or fourth generation is Drospirenone.
It's an analog of spironolactone.
There's no risk for hyperkalemia.
You don't need to be getting a K on these patients.
What do we need to know before we start this or continue it?
Their blood pressure and a review of the medical history.
That's it.
What's in the medical history?
Hypertension, diabetes, hyperlipidemia, migraine.
Now it's important to collect the gynecologic history,
but you do not need cervical cytology
before you prescribe contraception.
It doesn't have any bearing on that
because cervical dysplasia is caused by HPV.
Previous contraceptive methods, successes and failures.
Oh yeah, Dr. Weismiller, they put me on that Depot.
I had bleeding every single day.
So I want to get an Nexplanon, hmm.
You're probably gonna have bleeding every single day too.
Do they smoke and is there history
of veno thrombolic events?
What's the AAFP say in terms of choosing wisely?
Do not require a pelvic exam or other physical exam
to prescribe hormonal contraceptive in this case,
oral contraceptive medications.
There are benefits to these.
Less risk of ectopic, increases the bone mass.
Improves your symptoms of PCOS.
Low dose pills.
Great for management of the perimenopause.
They decrease fibrocystic disease, PID.
Importantly, they decrease cancer,
ovarian and endometrial and colorectal cancer.
Now hold onto your seats.
In terms of contraceptive failure
with combined hormonal contraception,
regardless of the vehicle,
these are the only medications you need to worry about.
Rifampin is the only antibiotic.
Now how many of you have prescribed Rifampin
in the last six months?
Okay, anticonvulsants.
All of them may have to worry about except Valproate,
any of the antifungals and the HIV medications.
Otherwise, not a problem.
Now, as we said earlier,
the funded research shows that women prefer fewer periods.
I'm always amazed at the number of females that I see,
which is the majority of my practice,
who have never had any discussion with anyone
about an extended cycle birth control.
Well, don't I need to have a period every month?
Won't it be dirty?
No, that's when we go through the physiology
and I actually bring up that slide
to show you're setting up housekeeping.
There's no guest.
So you just let things go to pot
and everything we just need to get rid of.
Now we're not having a guest.
So if we look at extended versus 28 day cycles,
IE, typically we're on an 84 day active pill
and then seven days of placebo.
People like this better.
So you take 84 hormonal pills.
So you give 'em four packs.
They don't take the placebo until the very last pack.
This is what's preferred.
There are many ways you can do this.
We even have one, Amethyst, which is a 365 day pill.
You take active pills every single day.
Now there are many continuous cycles
where you take a 24 or 26 days of active pills.
So your period's only two to four days.
Any of these can be used.
Now, progestin only pill,
this is gonna be over the counter.
It's been around since the early seventies.
Here's the problem.
The window, two hours.
The manufacturer says if you're three hours,
you should use a backup.
I have never, actually, I shouldn't say never,
I have only written a prescription for these pills
twice in my life.
I don't have patients who can do that.
Now if you're on them for other reasons
besides birth control.
So I have a transgender male on them right now,
works for him in terms of managing periods
'cause the testosterone does not completely control
the periods well right now he's not on them
for control of pregnancy, okay?
However, so they work.
The implant, you can use up to five years.
It's only FDA approved to three years.
Intrauterine system.
Depending on the one you choose, three to eight years.
Depot, there's a subcutaneous one you can prescribe.
They can do home use.
That's very helpful.
They don't have to come to the office.
The most common side effect, as we said,
of a progestin only is irregular bleeding.
Now here's how we manage unscheduled bleeding.
Now, when I put an intrauterine system hormonal in a patient
or a Norplant or Norplant and a Nexplanon, or Norplant,
my gosh, I took the last one out,
I think about a year ago.
Six rods, you remember that?
I think they had third year students put 'em all in
'cause every rod was in a different place.
So, you know, it took me forever.
You know the Nexplanon,
you can get out in about two minutes.
Okay, so the biggest side effect is irregular bleeding.
This is regular bleeding,
meaning I'm having a period every month,
no bleeding, irregular bleeding.
I can't tell where you're gonna be on this.
If you're on this end,
we're gonna work for nine months
to get you to this end before we take out this system.
I, that's the patient's agreement with me.
When I walk in to see a patient who's having a Nexplanon
or an intrauterine system put in,
which is long-acting reversible progesterone
and they're seeing a resident,
they have to be able to tell me the number one side effect
is irregular bleeding.
That's very important.
These are expensive systems.
If they have unscheduled bleeding
and ED said for five to seven days, any one will work.
You'll cut the bleeding anywhere from 50 to 90%.
If that doesn't work,
I add some fertilizer back
'cause I've sheared off the endometrium
because it's atrophic right at the roots
and it's just oozing.
Depot, you can use it more than two years.
No routine monitoring of bone density.
They should be on calcium
and do weight-bearing activity.
Benefits here, reduced endometrial cancer.
Really no increased risk of a DVT.
You decrease the risk of PID, ectopic primary dysmenorrhea.
Here's where I typically use progestin only methods.
Smoking, overweight, older hypertension, vascular disease,
older, lupus with vascular disease,
nephritis, meaning antiphospholipid positive.
Antiphospholipid negative,
they can use combined hormonal contraception.
We still recommend against migraine with focal aura.
Although I have transgender individuals who are on estrogen
who have migraine with focal aura.
Types of IUDs, copper or any of the progesterone only.
Why would I use a copper?
Well, you know, Dr. Weismiller, my periods maybe two days.
Light bleeding, never have a cramp.
Great, let's put a copper IUD in 35.
We put one in at 45 and we're done,
'cause we're gonna take it out at 55.
Oh, I got the periods from hell.
Bleeding all the time.
Don't, okay, let's use an intrauterine system.
They're approved for management
of dysfunctional uterine bleeding
or abnormal uterine bleeding.
Let's put in a Mirena.
It's good for up to eight years.
Insertion not use associated with PID.
They do not cause infertility.
You can use it in a nullip as long as the uterus sounds
to a minimum of six centimeters.
I know for some of you, you're like,
we put 'em in adolescents.
Yes, adolescents can use an IUD,
but supposed they get cervicitis or PID?
We used to take 'em out.
Now we just treat 'em.
If it doesn't respond, then we take it out,
but otherwise we screen them.
If they're at increased risk for STI put the IUD in.
If it comes back positive on their chlamydia or gonorrhea,
I treat them, okay?
Okay, that's the CDC 2010 said that we do not remove them
even with acute PID, unless they don't respond.
Noncontraceptive benefits here,
they decrease the risk of endometrial cancer.
The intrauterine system with a levonorgestrel,
IE hormonal, as I said earlier, many of these women,
you can avoid a hysterectomy.
Here are practice recommendations.
Please put those with your study folder.
Now, the barrier methods, sponges,
non menstrual toxic shock almost unheard of.
Diaphragm, they're gonna ask you about
increased incidence of UTI.
Latex condoms.
Very good at preventing STIs.
We were in St. Louis one year
and I was delighted to see,
I went to Maurizio's Pizza.
You can get a pack of condoms with your pizza.
You know, public health at its best.
Look at that.
Okay, natural family planning.
Well, Dr. Weismiller, you gotta be kidding me.
No, I'm not kidding you.
It works for people.
No adverse drug effects.
Immediately reversible,
expands couples communication
and forms of sexual expression.
The minus is you don't get the noncontraceptive benefits.
Most people are gonna have to periodically abstain
when you're most fertile and intensive education.
Breastfeeding and contraception.
The take home, this could be a whole conference.
All are available.
Okay, here's our next AES question.
According to ACOG,
use of emergency contraception is recommended
no longer than how many hours after inadequately protected
or unprotected intercourse
in women who do not desire pregnancy?
48 hours, 72 hours, 96 hours, 120 hours.
We have a learning opportunity, a 120 hours.
Okay, here are our post-coital treatments
for preventing pregnancy.
The FDA has approved it up to three days for progestin only,
but ACOG says you can use it up to five days,
which is all of them.
Now, you can use a selective
progesterone receptor modulator.
That's ella.
You can use progestin only.
You can use a combined pill.
You could even use a combined pill where you're like, well,
she has migraine with aura, she can't be on a combined pill,
for a short two segment course of,
a combination estrogen plus progesterone they can.
Copper IUD is FDA approved.
The Mirena has not been yet approved for this, okay?
Who gets this?
Who uses it?
Why do we use it?
It prevents fertilization
by inhibition of ovulation if hormonal.
Used after implantation in terms of hormonal,
it will not interrupt an established pregnancy.
Here are the indications,
inadequately protected or unprotected intercourse
and I don't desire pregnancy.
As we said, you can use it even in patients
where normally in a sustained use of that medication
could be potentially harmful
and it can be offered up to 120 hours
after unprotected intercourse.
There's no scheduled follow up required.
You only need a clinical evaluation
if the menses are delayed more than a week
after what you would've expected
or if they develop pain.
Here are practice recommendations related to contraception,
and we're gonna move to last, infertility.
This about affects about one in six people worldwide.
Here is the new definition
as of the 14th of October last year.
Infertility is a disease, condition or status,
characterized by any of the following,
inability to achieve a successful pregnancy
based on a patient's medical,
sexual and reproductive history, age,
physical findings, diagnostic testing,
or any combination.
Needful medical intervention
in patients having regular unprotected intercourse
and without any known etiology for either partner
suggestive of impaired reproductive ability.
Evaluation should be initiated at 12 months
when the female partner is under 35 years of age
and at six months when the female partner
is 35 years of age or older.
85% of couples should be able to conceive within 12 months.
Okay, now what's the etiology here?
Combined is most common male factor.
In women it's gonna be an ovulatory dysfunction,
tubal factor, or some other issue.
Unexplained is a quarter of them.
Now, here's the essential history.
How often are you having intercourse?
Are you using lubricants
because they can sometimes contain a spermicide.
Is there erectile dysfunction?
Is there dyspareunia?
Drugs and alcohol have a particularly toxic effect on sperm.
Caffeine will interfere with the muscle contraction
of the fallopian tube.
What medications are you on
and what is your chronic disease?
I had a patient many years ago come in
and he was really concerned.
They had a four or 5-year-old daughter
and had been unable to conceive since that child was born.
And I'm like, well, how often are you having intercourse?
He said, well, we haven't had it since she was born.
I am like, what's going on there?
She's, well, the child sleeps in the bed with us.
So I wrote a prescription, child to own room.
Within three months they were pregnant.
My dad's gonna be 90 in June.
I told him this story many years ago.
He said, "and that's why I paid for you to go
to medical school."
Hmm, okay, here's the essential history,
frequency, use of lubricants, drug or alcohol, as we said,
medications, and then caffeine.
And then you gotta always think about chronic disease.
Okay, now here's the next question.
Couple with 12 months of infertility
presents to the office for evaluation.
A semen analysis is completed,
found to be completely normal.
What is the first step
in evaluating the female?
Progesterone level, TSH level, FSH level or Estradiol level?
Okay, so we got a learning opportunity.
It is a progesterone level.
Okay, so let's take a look at this.
The primary objectives that work up semen analysis
and ovulation.
You can do a urinary LH or a mid-luteal phase
progesterone level.
Hysterosalpingogram.
If there's tubal obstruction,
that's same thing would be used
if there's a concern about a uterine cavity anomaly.
And then the serum FSH would be used
if I'm concerned about decreased ovarian reserve.
Now, the semen analysis, if it's normal,
you pursue other etiologies.
If it's abnormal, they go to a fertility specialist.
Now, in so doing,
you also need a testosterone in an FSH.
Know that smoking causes damage to sperm.
It decreases the sperm count.
It is associated with impotence.
Marijuana decreases seminal fluid, lowers total sperm,
contributes to abnormal sperm behavior.
They're dumb and it makes 'em dumber, okay?
Now, hypogonadism,
decreased testosterone level with an increased FSH.
That's gonna be primary.
Dr. Gilmore pointed that out to you.
Low testosterone, low FSH.
This is a morning signals a secondary cause.
Why might it be?
There could be a hyperprolactinemia.
These would be reversible with proper treatment.
What we do know is there's no evidence
that if you have a varicocele,
that treating this makes any difference
compared to expected management.
Now with the female evaluation,
you're gonna do an ovulation evaluation.
Now, how do I find day 21?
It's gonna be random guess.
Now, if the progesterone level is less than five,
I need to evaluate for cause here, TSH proactive, FSH,
do an estradiol level as we looked at
when we were looking at abnormal uterine bleeding.
If they're not ovulating, these are going to be important.
Now, keep in mind, if somebody has a systemic disease
and they're presenting with infertility,
you are gonna have other manifestations of that disease
before this is what they come in with, okay,
but keep that in mind.
Now, when we look at ovulatory disorders,
most of these are gonna be a dysfunction
of the hypothalamic pituitary ovarian axis
as we discussed in our last presentation.
That's gonna include things like PCOS and prolactinemia.
So typically, I can restore this if I can find out
what the underlying problem is.
If there's hypothalamic-pituitary failure, amenorrhea,
low gonadotropin levels,
most of these are going to be associated
with low body weight and excessive exercise
so I can correct that.
If they have ovarian failure,
most of these are only gonna conceive
with some type of oocyte donation
and in vitro fertilization.
But if I've got these disorders in terms of
hypothalamic pituitary ovarian axis,
most of the time this is gonna be an overweight person
or they're gonna have PCOS.
They're gonna benefit from weight loss,
increased physical activity,
and a lot of lifestyle modification
to restore their ovulatory cycles and achieve pregnancy.
Clomiphene can be used, as we said in the last presentation,
Letrozole can be used.
If the progesterone level is greater than five,
that indicates ovulation.
Here I'm gonna assess for some type of anatomic abnormality.
They'll either get a hysterosalpingogram
or they're gonna go for laparoscopy,
because I've either got tubal disease,
there's a cervical issue, there's an endometrial issue,
or perhaps there's endometriosis and a peritoneal issue.
Lifestyle factors very important here.
Abstaining from tobacco, limiting alcohol consumption,
getting that BMI under 30,
many of these patients will benefit from therapy.
There's a lot of anxiety and therefore increasing stress,
decreasing libido but keep in mind,
every person on this planet would benefit from a therapist.
Patients are always like, oh, Dr. Weismiller,
what would I talk about?
I promise you you'll find something to talk about.
Everybody would benefit.
Okay, here are SRT recommendations for practice
as we look at infertility.
Here are our practice recommendations
across women's health too that are most important.
I do wanna remind you from choosing wisely here
in terms of infertility.
Do not perform immunologic testing
as part of routine infertility evaluation.
They also say to go, they go on to say,
do not order routinely thrombophilia testing on patients
undergoing routine infertility evaluation.
And with that, I will say thank you very much.
We are done.
(audience clapping)
(chimes)